hi folks we'll be starting the free ail
master class in few minutes uh so we're
just waiting for folks to join in
meanwhile we'd love to know where you're
joining from I'm Russia Khan I'm your
host for today's webinar and I'm joining
from India I would love to know where
you are joining from please let us know
in chat here
let me also give my introduction on this
chat
okay I can see the introductions coming
in I can see folks have joined from
Africa Los Angeles Iran
Philippines Ethiopia India Kerala I can
see Ibrahim has run to Nigeria
I can see someone from Bangalore as well
India I can see uh sun is joined from
Afghanistan I can see shivangi Israel
from Boston I can see Peter has joined
in Northern California
awesome also please keep keep the
introductions coming in it's a good way
to network right these online events
before we start so we're just setting up
the project demo so let's start in next
two to three minutes
hi Jeremy can you check once
I've made you the panelist
yep I'm checking right now just to make
sure that
uh the iPad video will work
and looks like it perfect let me go
ahead and mount this on the stand
make sure that won't wiggle and then we
can start
cool I'm all set
um do you want to have been oh sorry do
you want me to build me this uh mode
like which is visible right now when you
require it
um Yeah so basically when we go through
the live demo parts of it will be on the
slide deck and then parts of it will be
um explained here kind of in like a
little whiteboard lecture session so we
can pin the video for that
um and then to show the code I'll
actually jump over to a Jupiter notebook
in our our Jupiter lab environment so
got it right
right okay I can see folks have uh okay
folks have given introductions and chat
so folks thank you so much for waiting
welcome everyone uh so we'll be starting
uh the free a master class and in this
we'll be covering how you can build your
own movie recommendation engine using
machine learning and also we'll be
having a catech program review which is
included in this webinar as well we
already have a speaker Here With Us
Jeremy
so I just will go through like few
ground rules
before we start uh so you need to go and
put any questions in the Q a box uh in
case you have a query uh and you want to
ask a question to a speaker here and the
session is being recorded so you can
expect a follow-up email with recording
link webinar certificate and a bonus
offer uh for attending this webinar and
also uh in case you want a web La
certificate with your full name so make
sure in the posts of it once we end the
session you will immediately get a post
survey uh link here and make sure you
put your full name in the post webinar
survey so this way we will be able to
give you the webinar certificate with
your full name
questions
okay on the Q a box that's great uh
introductions on chat questions on the Q
a box so before we start uh I would love
to know uh a little bit more about you
so you can see a quick call on your
screen uh so how many years of
experience do you currently have
before we start please uh quickly go and
go and vote for the quick quality screen
using right now how many years of
experience do you have you will see four
quick options the first one currently
studying second one zero to three years
of experience third one is three to five
years of experience at the last one more
than five years of experience
okay I can see folks are still joining
in and folks are pretty quick we have
gotten almost more than half of votes
for the cold uh that's great
but folks who have to joined in uh we
are starting the session now and before
we start we would love to know a little
bit about you before we start so you can
see a quick pull on your screen how many
years of experience do you currently
have so we can choose whichever is the
most suitable option for you on the poll
and submitter
because I can see almost 80 percent of
the folks are voted so few of the folks
who are left quickly go and vote for the
poll on your screen you're seeing right
now
okay I think uh we have gotten almost
all of the boards uh so I've been doing
the poll in five seconds so five four
three two one
okay let me in the poll and quickly
share the results as well uh so we can
see that folks here who are currently
studying they have them in more than
half the quantity and we can see for
folks have a few available experience
that you can see uh almost uh one third
of the folks have zero theories of
experience and also more than five years
I've seen so that's great thank you so
much for sharing this with us uh now
moving on to the agenda part so
um obviously
think to know more about you how we can
help you better in terms of
understanding your career in AML and
also uh any questions related to the
project in general you basically what we
covered in the program also in general
so you can let us know in the Q a box
will be taking those questions uh the
second part uh we'll be doing a live
project demo uh in basically how you can
build uh your own movie recommendation
engineering machine learning and also
we'll be giving a program introduction
of Caltech AIML mode cam the enrollment
steps will be shared once we share the
program preview and we'll be having a
special duration for the Q a part we'll
try to take as many questions during the
live project demo as well uh because I'm
pretty sure if questions related to the
project demo comes in that can be
answered that time if if the speaker has
time uh and we can take the rest of the
questions in the Q a section so yeah so
uh we already have a speaker Jeremy here
with us uh Jeremy would you like to give
your introduction
uh sure uh yeah so I'm Jeremy Samuelson
uh I am I've been a data scientist
machine learning engineer in industry
for a little over 15 years now
uh so presently I have myself listed as
the chief data scientist at Road Data
Solutions which is actually my own
consultancy so I actually uh have many
projects going on with many clients
uh my biggest client right now is
actually Equifax uh so I'm currently
working with their digital identity
engineering team
uh so that's a team that's responsible
for uh basically detecting identity
fraud in its various forms so you can
have all kinds of different ways that
people commit identity fraud
and uh basically they're looking to
implement machine learning and AI to
detect identity fraud
anytime somebody opens a new account so
it could be a credit card uh you know
Auto Loan mortgage any kind of
depository account like a checking your
savings account uh individual retirement
account anything like that
um where uh you know basically a
person's trying to open some kind of
financial account we then basically
provide guidance for the institutions
who would open and host those accounts
uh to let them know how strongly we
suspect uh that there's some kind of
identity fraud at plate
um
so yeah very exciting identity fraud and
financial fraud in general is actually a
very interesting exciting space to be in
uh there's a lot going on uh kind of at
any given time in that space so yeah
very very exciting
um
but uh yeah some other clients that I
have right now include uh I have a
compressed gas client here in the
Atlanta area where I'm located uh so
think about like industrial gases for
welding like acetylene industrial grade
oxygen uh They Also Serve clients in the
medical space so medical grade nitrous
oxide and oxygen as well for dentist
offices veterinary clinics uh doctor's
offices that kind of thing
and then also restaurants so they have
sort of a beverage grade CO2 vertical
and we're actually now getting into
propane which is a billion dollar space
to be playing in so very excited for
them uh so yeah and I've uh definitely
been able to help them kind of get into
that space because there were a lot of
data challenges actually uh with just
getting into that propane space in the
first place so uh which we can get into
later if you guys are curious about why
there would be data challenges for
propane uh but yeah so uh basically
uh yeah I've been doing this for a long
time serving clients in a lot of
different industry sectors and helping
them successfully Implement machine
learning and AI uh Solutions uh in many
verticals of many companies so that's me
um by the way that's really interesting
topic uh which you told basically you
can talk about later uh and also thank
you for uh thank you for introduction uh
so uh thank you so much I think before
we start the live project demo uh we
have a quick Hole uh basically why
exactly are you adding this webinar
today
so uh this webinar will be covering our
project live demo and also caltex cim
and boot camp as well uh so you can see
four quick options on your screen this
is a multiple choice questions so you
can select uh multiple options as well
because there can be multiple things you
are joining this webinar today for right
so you can see the first one I'm looking
to become an AI and ml professional you
can see the second one I want to learn a
new language or a skill I'm here to
understand if easy to learn the last one
I'm interested in working on new
projects from report for you so I can
see we are getting I think they have
gotten more than half of the words
you can let us know on the chat as well
so please do let us know we would love
to know
foreign
the highest number of votes for I'm
looking to become a AIML professional uh
I can see the second highest where I
want to learn a new language or skill
and also we've gotten uh votes for I'm
interested in working on new projection
portfolios right I think you're in the
right place you'll get a better
understanding for that during this live
project them as well and uh much more
projects which recover in the program
and the third one I'm here to understand
if eiml is easy to learn so uh I think
that makes sense uh let's start the live
project demo so over to you then
all right cool
um so let's see uh are you gonna drive
the slide deck while I talk yeah okay
sure
um yep so okay so today we're going to
learn uh how to make a recommendation
system or you know recommendation engine
is sometimes what they're called
um specifically for recommending movies
but really uh I mean as we're going to
show here uh in the next couple of
slides you actually can use these in all
kinds of contexts next slide please
Russia
foreign
so what are recommender systems so
basically this is a pretty broad term
actually uh but this describes a
specific family of machine learning
algorithms
um and they each kind of can do
different things
um but uh we'll we'll kind of talk about
some of the use cases but you could
actually argue that recommender systems
are quite possibly the most broadly used
type of machine learning in Industry so
many companies across many different
industry sectors are using recommender
systems
you know all the time and actually the
same company may even be using them in
many different contexts as well so we'll
talk about that in a bit uh next slide
all right so one possible use case uh
for recommender systems
are for search and for ads
um so for example you know if you're
searching on Google
um right how is Google so fast right
like how is Google
able to so quickly come up with you know
a bunch of results
um there are actually a lot of moving
parts to that same with Reddit and
Wikipedia uh but uh you know these are
going to use what we actually might call
something like pagerank algorithms where
uh the recommendation is not necessarily
tailored to an individual user uh so
each different user if you you or I or
any of us searched for the same thing on
Google or Wikipedia we would all see the
same results so the result isn't
necessarily tailored to us but these
search engines are essentially making
recommendations to US based on what it
has deemed to be most relevant uh based
on our search so we have these kinds of
algorithms these page rank ones we're
not going to actually discuss these ones
specifically today because this is sort
of not so much in the context of uh you
know movie recommender systems although
again in some contexts even something
like say Netflix or Hulu or any of these
streaming services we'll still use
something like this to some degree uh so
for example if you go to search their
catalog say there's some show you've
heard about and you're like oh I wonder
if this is on Netflix you go to search
their search engine that searches all
their content basically has to make a
guess at what thing you're probably
looking for especially if you don't
really know the the title of the movie
or the show you're looking for which I
I'm guilty of I quite often don't really
exactly remember the name of the show I
want uh so they have this sort of
recommender system that then figures out
what's probably the most relevant thing
that I meant to to find and then kind of
you know makes recommendations to me
based on that
so that's one thing little extension of
that actually that to show you how much
these are in use again Netflix or Hulu
do this all the time at least I've seen
this
where you search for a show say there's
something you want to watch uh and then
it turns out they actually at that time
don't have that show on the platform
maybe they used to have it on the
platform but it got taken off or maybe
it just never was uh but what's
interesting is they don't just say oh
sorry we don't have this if you've
noticed this if you search for a show
that's not on the Netflix platform
they'll actually say oh we don't have
this right now but if this is what
you're looking for here are some other
things that you're probably interested
in right so they actually do kind of
like just string right together these
two recommendations right of like hey
this is probably what you mean and we
don't have it but this is probably
something else you'd be interested in
right so uh yeah so a lot of these again
get used in a lot of different contexts
next slide please
all right and then this one uh comes up
a lot I know we've all seen this so uh
you know you log you know you hit the
amazon.com landing page and immediately
before you even search anything Amazon's
already making recommendations about
stuff you'll probably want to buy based
on things you've looked at before things
you've bought before all that kind of
stuff
um and this shows up again on you know
online Merchant store or websites like
Amazon
Etsy eBay and a million others that you
can probably think of I put Zillow on
there actually because that's kind of
top of mind for me
uh so my wife and I are looking at
houses right now uh and uh you know
we're looking to kind of move a little
bit further out from the Atlanta area uh
we're already a little bit outside the
perimeter but we're looking to kind of
move a little bit further out more into
the suburbs into maybe like the
Woodstock or Kennesaw area and I can
promise you Zillow definitely knows this
about us right so
so uh now I think just about every day
I'm getting emails uh and other
notifications from Zillow that are like
hey check out this new listing in
Woodstock that we think you'd like right
um and they're looking at things like
you know houses in our price range that
we've looked at number of bedrooms and
bathrooms like all that kind of stuff
zillow's making these determinations of
like hey you'd probably be interested in
this right uh so yeah I'm sure any of
those Real Estate websites Redfin any of
those are going to do the same thing as
well just like Zillow is so basically in
all kinds of contexts any time that you
have like stuff listed on a website
there's a recommendation or sorry a
recommendation recommendation system in
use uh to basically show you stuff that
you're you know likely going to like
right because they make more money
the more stuff you buy
and their catalog is so vast there's no
way that you're going to get through it
all yourself so you know basically the
these websites sort of help you out and
help themselves out at the same time by
showing you stuff that you're very
likely to buy
uh next slide please
okay and this is sort of our most
relevant sort of category of stuff for
today
um so sort of like con content
recommendation so we've got Netflix on
there of course but things like Spotify
Pinterest YouTube uh Instagram Snapchat
right all these different types of
social media uh anywhere where there's
content and really the way that these
businesses work uh well Netflix is maybe
a little bit different right so you have
you're on a subscription basis with
Netflix the more you find shows that you
want to watch the more worth it it is to
keep your subscription and keep paying
you know whatever it is they're charging
these days per month I don't even look
at it
um so I couldn't tell you what it is
what it is uh things like Spotify
depending on what kind of plan you're on
they actually play ads for you every so
often so the more songs you listen to
the longer you're on the app the more
ads they can play for you the more the
more money they make right so uh if they
play something you don't like you're
gonna end up skipping it or you know
you're going to turn the app off or
whatever so they definitely want to keep
playing stuff for you that they think
you're going to want to listen to same
with you know YouTube I think it's been
said about a lot of these platforms
Facebook all that kind of stuff the
thing that they really produce right the
thing that they really sort of like
manufacture and Export is your attention
uh right because that's how they make
money is having you you know look at ads
or you know especially if you click
through on these ads so they're actually
kind of two things at play there one
they want to keep showing you content
that they figure you're going to want to
stick around and consume right because
the longer you're on the platform the
more ads you're going to see uh the more
money they're going to make from those
impressions as they're called showing
you those ads but then all also they
make even more money if you actually
click through on the ad that you're
shown so there's also a recommendation
system trying to figure out what would
be the most relevant ad to show you that
you might like what's the ad that you're
most likely to click through on
um
so yeah in short there are a lot of
things you could recommend
uh you know uh it's it's really it'd be
hard to you know not come up with uh or
you know to tell you things that you
couldn't recommend right so you know
this is stuff that's used in the
financial system
to recommend products uh to you know
customers at retail Banks
um
to an extent actually some of this logic
that goes into recommender systems is
also used in algorithmic trading right
so you have to know like stock picking
so what what equities are we actually
going to like make a move on today based
on what's happening in the news what are
we seeing in the price action uh so you
know those those stocks that it's like
we should trade these stocks that's also
like basically a list of recommendations
right uh so really yeah no shortage of
things that you could recommend and you
know hopefully this illustrates just how
much uh these really are in use in
various sectors uh in the industry
um next slide please
yes sure
um
attention you know the audience has been
doing while you're speaking about the
life project yeah for sure so I forgot
to mention as well sorry the the type of
type of recommender system we talked
about or that recommends content is
called the one that we'll talk about
today is called collaborative filtering
I forgot to mention that so remember in
the search we talked about uh
oh go back back up I think we've there
we go uh back to the poll sorry
um so for the the search we actually uh
talked about that those are page rank
algorithms uh and for uh the content
recommendation those are collaborative
filtering so here's our poll question is
which type of recommender systems uh do
most companies use
this is a quick quick check to make sure
you're all with me
you can see a quick pull on your screen
uh which type of recommended system do
you do most companies use so uh you can
see four options here page rank
algorithms second one collaborative
filtering third one both four other
needle
okay I can see uh you know like two two
options getting almost close words so
let's see like if you're able to guess
this one
let's see how much attention you have
been doing so far before we start the
live project
okay I think I will end the poll in five
seconds because I can see it most of the
folks have answered the poll so five
four three two one okay let me share the
results as well so which one is the
correct answer I mean
uh so I was going to say both uh which
most of you got or the biggest chunk
have you got so that's great yep so
again uh uh a lot of companies so again
think of even YouTube right uh you're
searching for something in particular
there's a recommender system that has to
recommend the most relevant content
based on what you searched and then
based on stuff that you've watched
historically and stuff that you've
you're watching today uh they have to
then make content recommendations with
collaborative filtering uh based on you
know based on basically what they think
you're going to keep watching so that
you'll stay uh so that you'll stay on
the uh you know on the platform
all right
um so let's go ahead and go to the sort
of like live
demo
so um if you can pin the iPad
so we can see that and I'll kind of
sure I just stopped sharing my screen
this yeah should work now
uh I I hope uh the video is visible to
you folks you will see a white blank
screen which is pinned right now
uh
uh I think okay yeah actually let me do
this I'm going to go ahead and share my
screen
that that'll work for the coding portion
as well
you can
maybe it's not going to let me sorry
just one sec oh from where are you
trying to share which account
here we go
sometimes for some reason it just uh
like Grays out the option I don't know
what it okay so what you guys should see
is uh just a white screen uh you can see
my hand waving uh let me know if that's
visible to you guys
I guess I should watch the chat it
should be visible I think so please let
us know chat yeah all good yep okay good
good good okay so what I'm gonna do is
sort of explain this in a way that's
very intuitive
um you know so that we can just sort of
understand like the nature of what we're
doing and get an intuitive sense of like
how we go about making predictions
uh then
in anything like this you have to sort
of give sort of a uh mathematical
formality to what you're doing so that
you know kind of how to calculate your
predictions uh so all of that kind of
stuff will develop sort of here in this
uh on on this paper on my desk and then
I will jump over to a Jupiter lab that
we have in our uh Jupiter Jupiter lab
environment and show you guys the code
um Okay so
uh I did mention this type of algorithm
and again there are so many different
ways that you can go about uh doing uh
recommender systems
this is just one way
I will mention some others that are kind
of a bit deeper uh that you could
certainly cover in uh in the boot camp
uh in the sort of the broader program
again this is just sort of a tip of the
iceberg introduction today
so this is
[Music]
collaborative I had to think really hard
about how to spell it sorry
so collaborative filtering
and they're actually different types of
collaborative filtering you can do this
one that we're going to cover
specifically
is called
user user collaborative filtering so
we're actually going to be kind of
looking at different users and
essentially making tailored
recommendations to users based on what
other users seem to like so let's just
do like a really kind of quick silly
example of what this would look like so
let's say uh we've got three different
people on some stream service that uh
you know where you can watch movies
so let's say we've got sukesh
and so Kesh has watched a bunch of
movies and given ratings
so let's say that sukesh has watched
the Batman
uh he really really likes the Batman
because sukesh has excellent taste
um
he watched
[Music]
John Wick also very much like John Wick
right gave that 4.5 out of 5 stars
let's say then that he watched let's see
I'm gonna have to scooch this over so
you guys can continue to see
oh
sorry you guys are getting some memories
popping up online
so then
sukesh watched see Sue
they gave that a five out of five then
they also watched
for some reason 27 Dresses not really a
huge fan of 27 Dresses and they also
watched uh The Notebook
and also did not particularly enjoy the
notebook okay so these are the ratings
that sukesh has given for these five
movies in this example okay
now uh let's say we also have
Jeremy
Jeremy also liked the Batman
so Jeremy gave the Batman 4.5 Stars
Jeremy also liked John Wick so he gave
that one 4.5 out of 5 Stars
Jeremy hasn't seen sisu yet
and then also by chance he's also seen
27 Dresses and the notebook and didn't
particularly enjoy either of those
though uh gave those pretty low ratings
as well
now let's say we have
another user Sarah
and Sarah has essentially the opposite
Taste of these other two so she actually
did not like the Batman
uh I liked John Wick a little bit better
I mean Keanu Reeves is just so likable
um didn't like sisu but she loved 27
Dresses and The Notebook
so now the question is
do you recommend sisu to Jeremy yes or
no and why or why not
so
the logic here
is that if we look at say Jeremy and
sukesh at their ratings at least for the
movies where we actually have ratings
between the two of them
they actually really seem to closely
agree right so at least intuitively
Jeremy and sakesh seem to actually have
pretty similar taste
and also again for the movies that both
Jeremy and Sarah have rated they
actually seem to have kind of opposite
taste right anything that Sarah really
doesn't like Jeremy does like anything
that Jeremy Jeremy also sorry to
interrupt him
um okay yeah I think someone is not able
to see the canvas
um folks please let us know on chat here
is it visible to you like a whiteboard
which is writing on
it should be pinned to the screen
yeah it's visible yeah someone is
writing it's not visible so yeah
maybe you might have you know like uh
like might be viewing a different video
or something like that on the webinar so
just check out the canvas screen and
just click on it in case it's not
visible please continue sorry so yeah
actually if you guys aren't able to see
it
um from me pinning it I think you also
have the option of pinning it yourself
um in which case you can just watch it
uh as well directly
um so
basically here we might determine that
it would be a great idea to recommend
sisu to Jeremy because we think he would
like it right so uh kind of the more
formal kind of mathy way to say this is
uh Jeremy's ratings actually seem to be
very positively correlated with sukesh
so if sukesh likes sisu which he did
uh then we actually suspect pretty
strongly that Jeremy would also like
sisu because
so far everything else that the these
two users have in common everything that
sukesh likes Jeremy also likes so
there's this thing that sukesh liked
that Jeremy hasn't seen yet so uh we
should recommend this thing uh to to
Jeremy
um for some algorithms not particularly
the one that we're going to cover today
there's also quite a bit of information
in the relationship between Jeremy and
Sarah as well so these don't have
um a strong positive correlation uh but
they still are strongly correlated the
correlation just happens to be negative
right so again if Jeremy really likes it
we can count on that Sarah really didn't
like it and if Jeremy really didn't like
it we can count on that Sarah really did
so uh where Sarah really didn't like
sisu that is also actually pretty
indicative of
um that Jeremy would probably like it
so and I see some a couple of other
questions so a couple of you are asking
how do you pin video in the chat so uh
where uh the iPad which again is just is
going to show up as other Jeremy
Samuelson uh where that is uh a
panelists you're gonna be able to see
that up top if you actually just double
click on it that will automatically pin
it uh to your video so that that's the
only video that you see or if you right
click on it uh there will be an option
to pin it uh and then you uh yeah and
then you can see it
um maybe I'll just show you guys real
quick so I'm going to hit remove pin to
get it unpinned
so you can see it up here so there is an
option if you click on this uh to pin it
but if I just double click it then Zoom
actually just pins it to to my main
video
and then since I'm sharing my screen
that I'm able to see it hopefully you're
also able to see it that's why we're
doing it this way
okay
very cool all right so
um so that's the intuition anyway of how
we make recommendations in this user
user collaborative filtering but let's
also
[Music]
um introduce some notation so we can now
give this a bit more again kind of a
formal mathematical treatment
so this is arranged in kind of this
table
or in the context of machine learning
this is often thought of more as a
matrix
so the rows tell us or you know each row
is a user right a set of ratings for a
particular user
so
this will be n rows where n is
our number of users
okay
then the columns so like this column
here this is all the ratings
on the Batman right for people who have
rated the Batman that actually also
people who haven't so if a user has not
seen or has not rated the Batman their
entry will just be blank which is
actually fine that's exactly what we
want right
um
so you know I mean if you think about it
if your whole Matrix was actually filled
out there would be no recommendations to
make because every user has already seen
every movie and given you a rating on
whether or not they liked it so kind of
nothing for us for us machine learning
Engineers to do at this point if that's
the situation we have so we actually
count on uh this Matrix is going to be
very sparse and that a lot of values
will be missing which if you think about
it makes a lot of sense because
um
I don't even know how much stuff they
have on Netflix right now I imagine on
the order of like thousands of shows and
and movies
um I definitely have not seen anywhere
near all of the content right I've seen
a very very very small fraction of
what's actually there and uh you know
that's kind of probably what most people
are like right so probably most users on
the Netflix platform or any platform uh
have probably only ever consumed and
rated a very small fraction of what's
actually there to be seen
so
um
so at any rate this in this quick
example I filled out most of them but in
reality much of this table would
actually be empty so we have n rows
which gives us our number of users and
we have M columns which is our number of
uh I'm gonna actually say items here
because again
um
we don't have to necessarily just
recommend movies in this example we're
kind of going to use a data set that is
about movies but these could really be
about anything
all right and this I think is pretty
straightforward notation so far I don't
think anyone's going to freak out about
this the sex thing uh hopefully nobody
freaks out about so in math we like to
use a lot of these Greek characters so
we use Capital
Omega which is the last letter of the
Greek alphabet
and if we say
[Music]
Omega sub J
this would be
the set of all users
oops who have
rated
movie J right so basically any given
movie right the jth movie uh will be
rated by some people won't be rated by
most people so Omega sub J basically is
the set of all the people who have given
a rating to that particular movie okay
so
um that's what that notation means
um
so hopefully there are no questions
about that if there are go ahead and
drop those in the chat
so let's think about
kind of our approach
so sort of the naive approach here uh
that could be used and then actually in
the case of like page Rank and stuff
like that this actually is very much
what happens
um but uh what we're essentially
predicting here to make a recommendation
is a score
so we're going to label that s and I'm
going to say s
is a function of I and J
so in other words this is the score that
you would predict for user I and item J
so what score do you think user I would
give
to item J that you're recommending right
and this is ultimately how you make
recommendations right so it's not really
this deterministic answer where your
models like recommend this stuff don't
recommend this stuff
basically what your model really
predicts is the score that this user
would give to this particular item and
then you make recommendations based on
kind of the The Ordering of those scores
right so the thing that scores the
highest that's the thing you're going to
show to them first but then you know you
can kind of show them other things as
well sort of in descending order of how
high you think they would score them
so
basically
we could go
like this
so if I surround the set in these sort
of vertical brackets this is like the
size of the set right so the number of
things in the Set uh the nerdy math word
for that is the cardinality of the set
so
we basically sum
over all the users so I'm going to say
oh the I Prime in
Omega sub J so I'm using I prime just
because I'm summing over users but user
I is the user in particular that I'm
interested in
um
so we're summing over all the users that
have given a rating to this thing in
question
and we're basically summing up their
rating
okay
write the rating from you know each User
it's a user I prime for
item J we add up all those ratings and
then we divide by the number of people
who have given such a rating so
essentially that would just be sort of
the average of the rating right so the
average rating uh which this is an
entirely naive approach this is not
tailored to our users right so under a
scheme like this every user would
actually basically see the exact same
recommendations right we are not in any
way considering a user's taste uh this
is literally just kind of like hey
everybody overall seems to like this
movie so you know here's here's this
recommendation for this movie
so the way that we actually can fix this
because we don't really want to do this
[Music]
what we want is we actually want to
consider
more strongly
users that are more similar to the user
in question right just like back in the
the table that we sort of constructed
for our intuitive example uh right so
like for example in making
recommendations to Jeremy we actually
want to consider sukesh more strongly
than we consider other users because
sukesh is very very correlated with
Jeremy
so
um
we're going to introduce this idea of
actually doing sort of a weighted mean
so instead of just doing a straight up
average
of our recommendations we might actually
uh do this weighted average
[Music]
where again we're summing over
all users
who have given a rating to item J
and then their rating is weighted by
their weight
between the user I and the user in
question right between user I and user I
prime so the rating
of user I Prime
gets weighted by this weight for how
much do we want to consider that that
particular user or that particular
user's tastes when we're making a
recommendation to user I and then to
make it so that this
average kind of comes out correctly
or you know kind of gets scaled
the way that we want
we then
[Music]
sum up
for
the magnitudes of all these weights
because again the weights actually could
be negative
um so that's actually what we're
ultimately kind of going to do although
at this point I have not told you guys
how exactly would we calculate these
weights
so we are going to get to that we are
going to talk about exactly how these
weights are calculated
but first there's actually another
consideration that we have to make and
that is
that we have to
consider oops we'll move that back down
user bias
so basically different users are going
to have different behaviors in terms of
how they rate things and this is also
something we have to consider right so
um you know one user maybe they actually
really dislike most things and so most
movies they just rate a one and if they
really really like something maybe
they'll give it like a 3.5 or maybe a
four if they absolutely loved it but
they don't give anything a five right so
maybe that's that user's Behavior
on the other hand another user might
actually be you know give most things
like a four or a 4.5 and if they really
really love it they you know they give
it a five and then they basically have
never given anything a one ever if they
really don't like a movie they might
give it a two or a 2.5 right so you have
these two different users uh that are
kind of severely biased in One Direction
or another
um
and that there's you know there's kind
of a whole spectrum of like how biased
different users might actually be
so we have to be able to account for
that and so to account for that what we
do is we say you know what I actually
don't care so much about the absolute
rating values themselves
uh what I care about more
is how much do how much is this rating
from a particular user deviate from the
average rating that we see from this
user right so
we're going to say actually that we have
this
deviation which I'm going to denote with
lowercase Delta
so the deviation
for user I
for item J
is actually going to be
the rating
that user I gives to item J
minus
I'm going to say R Bar which is the
average rating
the user I has given four things that we
know user I has rated right so uh for
basically all the sort of known readings
that user I has given what's the average
and then basically what's the rating
that they give to this thing
minus that average right so now instead
of thinking about there's just in
absolute terms what is their rating
we're thinking more about how does each
rating kind of deviate from that
person's mean right
now we can actually restructure our
prediction for how do we think this
person is going to like how do we think
this particular user would score this
item
and we can actually make that prediction
more in terms of or exactly in terms of
uh what do we think would be their
deviation from their mean right so based
on how other users have deviated from
their mean and their rating of this
thing how much would this user deviate
in their main rating in reading this
thing
so essentially
we're going to estimate this deviation
so in sort of statistical estimator
Theory
one thing that we do sort of a little
Nuance of our notation you'll get used
to I guess is if there's this real thing
that is a real value to be known and we
want to estimate that thing our
statistical estimation of that thing we
put this little carrot on top we call
this hat so if Delta is the real thing
we're interested in Delta hat is our
estimator of that thing so basically
we're going to estimate
Delta
so we want this estimation of the
deviation
which we can again just sort of uh
estimate as an average of this
particular user's deviation from their
mean right so this would be
my marker is drying out just a bit
so
or sorry actually I think I believe I
said that wrong to make sure I'm not
confusing anybody
uh so if we want to predict a user's
deviation uh from their mean score from
their mean rating on item J uh what
we're actually going to do is again
we're going to consider users that are
uh closer to them right that are similar
to them and we're actually going to look
at for those users what is their sort of
average deviation from their mean on
this thing
so
summing Over All
users who have given a rating to item J
we look at their deviation which is
again their
score that they've given
to item J
minus
the mean of all the scores that they've
given right and bear in mind we're
summing over this I prime so this is all
contained within that sum
all right so then
our users score that we're estimating
you could say is actually
their average score
for this user which actually sort of
represents the bias for this particular
user right so sort of on average how do
they rate things
Plus
their estimated
deviation
for
item J
so this is actually going to be
our
um
our estimations or essentially our
estimated score for how much do we think
user I is going to like item J right how
do we think they would score this stuff
so then kind of inserting everything in
just fully flesh this formula out that
we're going to be implementing in code
we have that our estimated score for
user I of item J
is going to be
[Music]
the average score from user I
Plus
now this formula for the
average deviation and again we want to
make sure that this is the weighted
average deviation for
users that are similar again in terms of
their taste to this user in question so
this would be
the sum
over all the
all right it's getting a little bit
small
I sub Prime in
Omega J so basically again over all the
users who have given a rating for Omega
J
we have the weight between the user in
question and the user that we're
comparing them to
and then we're looking at that user's
deviation so they're rating for this
thing
[Music]
minus that user's
average rating
and then again to make sure that this
actually all comes out to
an appropriate average
we're then going to
[Music]
sum up all of our
weights
as well and again accounting for that
they could be positive or negative
we take the absolute value
so finally this is actually our
um
prediction uh this is our formula for
making a prediction right our estimated
score for user I on item J
um in practice though we actually
sometimes do this without that user's
average score
um which a little bit makes sense if you
think about it because for this
particular user right for user I
their average is actually always the
same right so this is essentially a
constant for a given user right for user
I so then essentially the thing that
they would score highly would be a thing
that has the highest positive deviation
from their their average
so essentially all the information
really is in this term here where we get
this average deviation
um but again yeah some some sometimes
you can use it uh I mean you can use it
if you want to to have the whole formula
or you can just look at the deviations
both are technically going to get you
the same answer so they're both the
correct way to go about it
all right
so now
um
now is sort of the question of
we've been talking about these weights
for these weighted averages
so how to calculate the weights
foreign
and this is actually relatively
straightforward especially if you have
um
you know
have any kind of background in
statistics or probability this is going
to be probably pretty intuitive for you
uh I do see someone mentioning something
about the hamiltonian of the Matrix
um
so I guess I'll let me acknowledge that
really quickly
um there are lots and lots of methods
for doing this
uh there are lots of methods for even
calculating or you know giving a
collaborative filter
um many of these actually involve
different
um methodologies of decomposing The
Matrix right so you can do like a single
singular value decomposition uh many
other types of decompositions uh and
then depending on what type of
decomposition you do there are different
kind of techniques uh for again how you
actually ultimately arrive at the sorry
the score that we just calculated that's
uh that I've just put away
but uh so uh where most of you uh kind
of from our poll earlier uh
fully 75 percent of you I believe uh are
either still studying like you're still
in school or have little to no
experience
um I'm not really going to dive too much
into those types of techniques
um so but I will actually kind of warn
you guys if you do want to pursue
knowing this and like really knowing it
um you will want to brush up on your
linear algebra so that you are more
familiar with those Matrix
decompositions uh because Yes actually
to do many of these uh techniques more
efficiently and frankly as efficiently
as you would kind of need to be uh to
implement this stuff in industry
uh then uh yeah you're gonna need to be
familiar with all that stuff
um and actually to be completely Fair uh
if we wanted to actually think about
like
companies like Netflix Hulu you know any
of those how are they doing this today
um I would bet that very few of them are
actually still using collaborative
filtering today
um again this is very much like an
introductory algorithm so I'm showing
this to you guys sort of as an
introduction to uh how to recommender
systems work how does collaborative
filtering work
um if you were to ask me to guess how is
Netflix doing this today uh I would
almost certainly wager that they're
using some type of deep neural network
architecture and in particular it would
have to be something like Auto encoders
or uh type of unsupervised Network
called a restricted boltzmann machine
um so
uh yeah there are a lot of more
sophisticated techniques out there than
what I'm showing you today uh but again
where some of you are where you know
three out of four of you uh are probably
brand new to this uh I don't want to
throw you into the deep end of the pool
I want to show you I want to show you
guys a good starter starter way to do
this and then uh that you know gets you
hungry for more uh check out the boot
camp uh we we get a lot into
uh the different deep learning topics
and in fact just as a bit of a an aside
um yeah we do cover deep learning we do
cover Advanced deep learning with
computer vision natural language
processing and uh even things like
recommender systems as well so that's
absolutely something you can dive deeper
into if that interests you in the boot
camp
um okay uh so back to uh sort of the
thing at hand uh with our statistical
collaborative filtering
um so essentially
if you've taken a stats or probability
class
you may remember
uh there's this kind of famous guy in
statistics and probability his name's
Pearson
so he actually has this uh statistic
called correlation so if you have two
variables X and Y
uh then you can actually calculate their
correlation
thusly
[Music]
so here in the
denominator
we end up taking the sum
[Music]
and we'll say as I goes from 1 to n so
we have n observations in our sample
of x sub I minus X bar squared and we
take the square root of that
multiplied by
the sum as I goes from 1 to n
of
Y minus y bar squared and then in the
numerator we actually just get the sort
of cross
uh
it's not exactly the cross correlation
but uh sort of a
sort of like cross
term here of these
so we get x minus X bar
times
y minus y bar so this is how we would
just calculate the correlation of two
random variables uh that we've observed
so what we're essentially going to do
here is we're going to let the weight
between two users be
this correlation essentially adapted to
observations that we have about these
two users
so we have
that our weight between
user I and user I Prime
is going to be
[Music]
let's see and I have to pick a new
variable here so let's go
that this is the square root of the sum
we'll say j in
it's another
uh we'll just say
a which a is the set of all movies that
these two users have in common
so for all the movies that uh user I and
user I prime have in common
we're going to add this up so we have
all the ratings from
uh
user
I on all the movies that he has in
common he or she has in common with user
I Prime
minus the average rating
from user I squared let me take the
square root of that whole thing
and then similarly we take the square
root of the sum again over
all the movies that these two have in
common
and we look at the ratings
from user I Prime
for all of these
different things different movies items
whatever
minus the average rating given by user I
Prime
squared we take the square root of all
that and then up here on top we again
get this kind of
cross product thing
so again summing up over
all the movies that these two have in
common
and we get the deviation for user I
which is
user i j
minus r bar for user I
multiplied by
R sub I prime J because this is for the
other user
minus the average rating from user
I Prime
so we really do just take this Pearson's
correlation and just essentially
calculate the correlation between these
two users given the things that they
that they have in common right given the
the movies that they have both given a
rating to
all right
um
[Music]
then
let's see I think actually how are we
doing on time Russia I'm not sure how
much time I actually have for this
um so yeah something I could skip before
running low yeah maybe maybe we can cut
it short a little bit but we can extend
like for a few minutes you know as
you're comfortable sure okay all right
so
um something I was just going to mention
it's actually very very similar to
Pearson's correlation that is also
commonly used is called the cosine
similarity which is essentially how you
use the angle between two vectors to
determine how similar they are
so
um but yeah that's just kind of the
thing that we'll mention quickly as sort
of an alternative that you could use in
your implementations
so now there's kind of a problem of what
if the two users don't actually have any
movies in common
uh what do we do then
it's actually quite simple uh we
actually just don't consider the two
users in each other's predictions
um and in fact
um
typically we actually in practice we'll
set sort of a threshold of how many
items or how many movings these these uh
users have to have in common uh for us
to even consider them which again from a
statistical perspective just makes sense
if you don't have enough data then your
statistical estimations are you know not
going to be very sound
and also for sort of uh
consideration of runtime complexity or
you know uh sort of complexity of your
algorithm so that it runs somewhat
reasonably
uh we actually often don't calculate
scores or don't uh kind of consider the
scores or the weights for
um every user you know for every other
user when we want to make a prediction
for every user uh we actually again just
look at the similarity between users and
we'll do sort of a essentially K nearest
Neighbors which is another machine
learning algorithm
um but the idea is that basically we'll
say k is like 25 or maybe upwards of 50
depending on how large the data set is
and then we'll essentially say when
we're actually making predictions for
this user
um we're only going to consider the 25
most similar other users uh you know
when we when we compare them so that's
kind of how we do that in practice
[Music]
uh so now quickly I will
jump over to our Jupiter notebook
environment
so we'll unpin this
and I'll just show you guys this in code
really quickly
um oh I should zoom in
I always find when I'm teaching that
they need it a little more zoomed in to
be able to see okay
so
um oh that actually still is running
shoot
oh I see okay looks like we had a little
bit of a server issue so I've lost my
compute kernel uh which is unfortunate
so okay okay so I will show you the code
unfortunately looks like the end of it
didn't run I reran uh re-ran a bunch of
it so that it would kind of be presented
more in order and look nice and it looks
like I lost my compute kernel part way
through so I do apologize for that
Okay so
uh so here we actually are doing some
imports uh so we're importing pickle
which is essentially sort of this
Universal uh way of saving files and
loading files back up so yeah if you're
unfamiliar literally any kind of python
object that you can come up with you can
save that uh with pickle and then reload
it again later so very very handy
uh then we have numpy and pandas which
are absolutely core Staples in the data
scientists uh toolbox and then for this
particular use case there are just some
things that I'm gonna use so uh counter
from the collections Library Shuffle
which is a utility from scikit-learn and
then sorted list which is a nice object
from the excuse me from the assorted
containers Library
all right so uh quickly we did have to
do some data processing on this
data set so here's the link here if you
guys wanted to get a hold of this data
set and use it yourself so you can find
this on kaggle uh kaggle.com datasets
Slash group lens
slash movie lens this is the movie lens
Dash 20m dataset so this is quite a
large data set this is 20 million movie
ratings
so it's very large file in order to
actually get this to run on the compute
cluster that we have available in our
Jupiter lab because they're not you know
massive compute instances
um I'm gonna have to actually sort of
pair this data set down just a bit so
you guys will kind of see how I do that
in practice
again if you were to do this it say
Netflix or anywhere else you would
actually be using something like spark
uh to do sort of this like uh
parallelized you know cluster Computing
um but again want to keep this entry
level for everybody just kind of give
you an idea of how this gets done
um so we're instead just gonna
um
Pare down our data set to a more
manageable size
so we read this in
kind of a good thing to do is to sort of
run this head method on your data frame
just to look at the first five rows and
just get a sense for what you uh what
you have here
we can see that in terms of the number
of variables we have or the number of
columns not too many at all uh this
really is just you know a lot of
observations that are very very simple
so we have the user ID
so user one has been very busy they've
you know clearly given ratings to a good
number of movies we have a movie ID we
have a rating which can have a minimum
of 0.5 stars or a maximum of five stars
and then we have the time stamp which
we're going to go ahead and just drop
because our algorithm doesn't use it
all right so uh I've kind of checked
this and found that
our user IDs are sequential and they go
from zero to about a hundred thousand
they're about a hundred thousand users
and
um so we don't want this to start at one
in programming we typically like things
to be indexed starting at zero so I'm
actually just going to subtract one from
every user ID so that our user IDs are
now zero to again actually about a
hundred thousand
um
looking at the movies found that they're
actually only about twenty thousand
unique movie IDs in the data
um but again probably due to movies
being sort of taken off you know or you
know put on the platform then removed
they want every movie ID to have kind of
a unique uh you know a unique ID for
each movie
um but as it is in the data set
um we actually have our movie IDs also
going up to about a hundred thousand uh
even though they're only about twenty
thousand in there so they're kind of off
by you know a whole order of magnitude
uh so just sort of for ease of handling
we're going to create a new mapping that
assigns new movie IDs that go from zero
to about twenty thousand so that's what
this code does here
um so yeah we get all of the unique
movie IDs we create this movie to index
dictionary
we start our index at zero and then
basically we go through
all of our unique movie IDs and then
make this we kind of populate this
dictionary with the movie ID and its
index
and again we're incrementing the index
every time we do that and ultimately uh
once we have this dictionary that gives
us a movie and an index a new index then
we go ahead and create a movie index
variable in our data frame by using this
apply method on the data frame
and then to drop the timestamp very
simple there's just the drop method so
we just give it a list of columns that
we want to drop in this case the only
one we actually want to drop is
timestamp everything else will hang on
to
now is the part where we actually want
to go ahead and Shrink things down
so ultimately what I've done here is
I've picked the 10 000 most active users
so these are sort of like the top 10 000
users in terms of like these are the
people that have rated the most movies
uh and the uh 2000 most rated movies
right so we have the most active users
that are giving the most ratings and the
most actively rated movies uh so that we
can again have an interesting data set
to work with but also one that's
considerably smaller uh than the
original one that we had because again
for for our little compute instance here
it turned out to be too much to uh to
try to Crunch the whole thing
um so
basically we have to count up how many
times each user ID in movie index occurs
uh then we extract the users and movie
IDs uh from the most common 10 000 and
the most common 2000 respectively
and then
we filter our original data frame to
create this small data frame
uh now what we have is again uh this
entirely different sort of uh indexing
of user IDs and movies so we're just
going to quickly re-index that so that
we uh again have everything in order for
easier handling
uh then finally if you're dealing with
limited compute resources this is an
important step
uh so once I've done all that processing
which actually took uh quite a bit of
run time to do I went ahead and saved
this smaller data frame
to a CSV so that now if anything kind of
breaks or goes down if I lose my compute
kernel going forward I don't have to
redo all that stuff right I can just
load in uh this smaller rating data set
here so that's what this says so this
loads this in
again checks the first five rows so that
we have any idea what we're looking at
and also to kind of confirm that your
import worked is intended
uh now this is something that you don't
typically do in machine learning uh so a
lot of these
um
you know
methods that use things like singular
value decomposition and all that kind of
stuff frankly you don't really want
those data sets in a data frame uh
pandas data frames are nice for
some types of analysis actually a lot of
analyzes
but they're not the fastest objects
really so
yeah basically
uh so even though we have a smaller data
frame uh this still is not going to be
the most efficient computationally
speaking the most efficient way to kind
of keep our data
so just because of how
these objects are structured in Python
if we wanted to say you know Loop
through do something that where we have
to Loop through all end users and all M
movies which we would have to do in
order to uh you know get ratings from
each user on each movie you know or even
check to see if there is a rating for a
user in a movie
um that operation broadly speaking is on
the order of O of n times n sorry n
times m
and again that's actually just for one
user so actually if you want to now
generate a prediction for all end users
that now becomes o of N squared times M
so we have this kind of uh
cubic runtime uh which is not great uh
so if we have a dictionary and we want
to go through all the ratings that
operation actually just has a run time
of order uh o of magnitude of Omega here
so this is uh considerably
better run time if we organize things
into dictionaries here again this is not
necessarily how you would want to do
this all the time but for this
particular data set and given the
limited compute resources we have this
is actually going to be a little bit
better a way to do it
so and then the last thing here so we're
also going to split our data set into
sort of a training data set and kind of
a validation dating a validation data
set because what we want to do is uh you
know we don't just want to look at our
model's error or our model score
model performance maybe more broadly
just in our training set
we want to make sure that what the model
has learned actually generalizes well
beyond the training set and so when we
kind of you know
see new observations our model is going
to be able to make good reliable
predictions so that's why we would have
this other data set
so
you want to figure out how many users we
have how many movies we have
than what we do in this case we don't
have a sequential data set so it's
perfectly fine for us to shuffle it up
uh in fact we want to do this to
randomize it and then basically we want
to cut it off at
that the first 80 percent
now the observations we'll use to train
the algorithm and then the last 20
percent
will do for sort of a validation test to
make sure that again that our model
still scores well outside of um
outside of training
all right and then we're going to need
to construct a few different
dictionaries here uh so we're going to
need a user to movie dictionary a movie
to user dictionary
and then a given a user movie pair we
can get a rating and again for both the
training set and the test set
so
uh
the logic for this is actually pretty
simple
so this is a function we're going to
Define functions to do this the function
considers or takes a row of a data frame
so then we Define these kind of index
variables I for the user ID J for the
movie index then basically we check to
see is this user ID in the user 2 movie
dictionary if it isn't then we add this
user movie pair in
and again we add in the the value as a
list as a Singleton list at first if
this user already appears in this
dictionary then we go ahead and append
the movie to their list of movies uh
that they've given a rating to
that exact same logic happens in Reverse
here in the movie to user dictionary
and then we're actually just it's pretty
straightforward to then populate this
user movie to rating dictionary uh
by just using the user and movie pair as
the key and then populating that with
the rating that that user gave to that
movie
uh then we have to do a simpler function
here for the test portion uh we actually
will have covered everything that we
need in terms of the user to movie and
movie to user but we will need this user
movie to rating uh dictionary for the
test set as well
so we Define this separate function that
does that part and then we apply these
functions to the train and test set
respectively so that uh
so that we have what we need there
all right then this is a sort of another
Place solder thing
so ultimately the data that I'm going to
use for the model
are going to be these dictionaries
so again to make sure I don't have to do
all that processing over again because
there was a lot of run time involved
with that
then I actually just saved these I ended
up saving them with a DOT Json
extension because they are
dictionaries and Json is kind of the
format you would do that with but again
these were large enough it was kind of
giving me trouble so I actually just
wrote These as binary so even though
they have a DOT Json extension these are
just binary files
so again if anything goes wrong later
which it did uh that I didn't have to do
all this work again so I can actually
just reload those dictionaries and then
move on
all right so now uh for the actual
collaborative filtering part then this
is the part that unfortunately the
kernel stopped while this was running
um so I'm not sure I'd have to reset it
to get it back so we'll just kind of go
over the code unfortunately sorry about
that
um so
basically we need to make sure we have
uh so it turns out all the users are
fine but where we only have 2 000 movies
there's kind of this chance that we may
have some movies in the training set but
not in the test set or vice versa so we
need to kind of again sort of capture
exactly what our uh you know kind of the
a number of users and number of movies
that we that we have from these
dictionaries in case we've reloaded them
uh so then what we do to calculate the
weights for each user pair again using
only the 25 most similar neighbors or
most similar users
um
and we also need to make sure that in
order for any two users to be considered
for each other that they also have at
least five rated movies in common
so we set K to 25 which is how many
neighbors we're going to look for
we have
five is the threshold for that we have
to have at least that many movies in
common and then we're going to create
these
lists for Neighbors averages and
deviations
so now this is the part that's o of N
squared times M so we have for each user
we're going to have to go through
and then basically get
all of their
ratings
their average ratings
their deviations and then we're going to
calculate this this Sigma I this is the
square root of their squared deviations
from the denominator of
the Pearson correlation that we
calculated so that's all that's
happening there
then we save their average and their
deviation
now for the Neighbors part we're going
to use this sorted list so the sorted
list actually keeps things you know in
order so that we can you know if we keep
this thing
down to only 25 then we know that the 25
things are sort of the uh the 25 most
most similar neighbors for user I
so we have user I
we're now going to look through all
these other users that we're going to
index with j
first we need to make sure that we're
not comparing a user to themselves
because that's not useful to do
so as long as this is not the same user
we're going to actually do all the same
stuff for user J so we're going to look
at the movies that they have
um
that they've rated
and then we're going to get the set
Union of the movies that user I has
rated and the movies that user J has
rated so that this is their movies in
common
we make sure that movies in common is at
least five movies
and then if if that's true
then we actually calculate all the stuff
for user J that we calculated for user I
so all their ratings their average
ratings uh their deviations and then
their the square root of their the sum
of squared deviations for them
so we calculated all that stuff because
that's what we needed ultimately to
calculate the weight
between these two users between user I
and J
so once we have that we're going to add
that to our sorted list and I'm negating
it because this automatically sorts in
ascending order so this just kind of
automatically keeps it in the order that
I want
we just have to remember that it's
negated later in the code uh then
basically
if
our sorted list has gotten to be greater
than the number of neighbors we want to
check then we just drop the last thing
off of that list so that again this
sorted list is always the 25 nearest
neighbors to your user I
so then once we have done that then for
user I we can actually save their 25
nearest Neighbors
so that's essentially what this block of
code does
is for each user we go through and we
get the weights between that user and
their 25 nearest Neighbors
now we're going to go ahead and Define
this predict function so given a user I
and a movie m
um what's our
predicted score for this user in this
movie
so we start out with
just setting our numerator and
denominator to zero because again we're
going to calculate their
sort of predicted deviation from their
average
now we could do this thing where we say
you know if
um
you know if these if these things uh or
you know if if this movie is in this
dictionary for deviations
then look it up
unfortunately this is already
computationally very expensive and we
would basically then have to
kind of go through all the keys in that
dictionary to look up you know whether
or not this thing is in there and then
we would need to look it up again if we
chose to actually use it so we want to
avoid doing that look up twice so
uh what we're going to do is we're going
to enclose this in this sort of python
code structure where we try to do
something
if it works great if it doesn't work
then we can kind of gracefully handle
the exception so we're going to try
to add
this
weighted deviation to the numerator and
the absolute value of the weight to the
denominator
if that works great if it doesn't work
uh which would happen because we
you know don't have this uh this movie
in uh in this dictionary
then basically we just go ahead and
return a key error exception and then we
use this pass to mean that we just
continue on so that the error doesn't
like stop our script basically
um
and if it happens somehow that we have
the denominator still sums up to zero
uh then we basically just go ahead and
predict
the user's average rating for their
average uh otherwise we go ahead and uh
predict the
weighted average of deviations from
their K nearest neighbors and then add
that to their average rating right then
this is actually not uncommon to do in
like real implementations where
you know again sort of constrain the
model output based on some kind of
business logic so
in reality this prediction is sort of
unconstrained this could end up being
kind of anything
um so if you think that this person
you know really loves this movie you
might have given them like a six or a
seven or whatever but again they're
supposed to get you know ratings on 0.5
the scale of 0.5 to 5. so basically if
it's over five you knock it down to five
if it's below 0.5 you bump it up to 0.5
because that's the range that these uh
ratings have to be on
um
yeah
um you actually could possibly in some
algorithms or in some situations
make the argument that um
you actually maybe don't want to do this
part yet uh because if you have say a
movie where someone you predict that
they would give it like a 4.8
and then you have another movie where
you predicted they would give it like a
6.5
or well actually let's even just say you
think they'd give it a five and you
think the other one they would give a
6.5
this logic would actually just make them
both five so then they're both kind of
like equally likely to be recommended
whereas the second one you probably
should recommend over the first one
because we really really think they
would like that one
um when I was tinkering with this
earlier though uh applying this business
logic actually didn't really affect the
mean squared error of the model at all
so uh I mean at least not notably right
uh but there was it was always kind of
within Striking Distance whether I did
it or didn't so uh turns out that's you
know this isn't really a hamstringing
our model too much at all
and again whether it's actually kind of
hurting your model's performance or not
sometimes business logic is just
not optional so so something to think
about as well uh so once we've kind of
calculated our prediction
made sure it fits within the range
defined by the business uh then we go
ahead and return our prediction
and then finally these last two cells
here actually get our uh predictions
on both the training and test set
so yeah we get
um in this case
the user the movie and then the target
which is actually their rating
then we get a prediction on what do we
think this user would give as a rating
to movie m
and then where it's a movie that we
actually have seen the rating for them
for
we've actually seen this user give a
rating we can see how close our
prediction actually was to the Target
right so we saved the prediction and the
target
and then we do the same thing for the
test set
and then ultimately we have our mean
squared error which is straightforward
enough to uh
yeah to calculate so given we have a
list of predictions and a list of
targets
we convert these to numpy arrays so that
we can actually have this nice sort of
element-wise operation happening to it
so we calculate the difference between
the prediction and the target we square
that difference and then we take the
mean to get the mean squared error and
then we print those out so again I
apologize that we lost the our status on
the compute kernel is unknown so I I
lost the compute kernel uh the last time
I ran this
um but when I ran this before
um I was getting a mean squared error of
about 0.45 on training and about 0.6 on
uh testing which is actually not too far
off of the the current Benchmark for
this movie lens data set so I to be
honest I was a little pleasantly
surprised uh that this very basic
statistical algorithm actually performed
so well again given that uh there's so
much other stuff out there like Auto
encoders restricted boltzmann machines
um you know all these crazy deep
learning implementations uh interesting
that this actually still
still got so close uh to to The
Benchmark on this data set so yeah
fascinating I wish that was still
printed out here
but it's not unfortunately so sorry
about that okay
um so that is let me go ahead and give
this back to Russia
um so that is the demo oh I have to go
stop sharing
yes okay
um so that's the demo I know Rasha still
has some more stuff to cover so I will
give it back to Russia uh thank you so
much Jeremy for taking us through the
project demo
and we have gotten quite great questions
here in the Q a box we'll be taking that
in some time uh so let's move on to the
program before that we would love to
know how interested are you in learning
the the community system architecture
such as AES and rbms uh so I'll quickly
launched a poll here it's a very easy
quick poll uh with three three quick
options here the first filming me and
the second room I mean I'm pretty
interested I guess and the third one I'm
super interested
I can see the third one getting uh the
highest highest number of words and uh
we will be going to the I I think a few
folks have put down questions on the
chat I'm so sorry we have gotten a lot
of messages while uh Jeremy was doing
the demo so please please go and put on
your questions on the Q a box uh so
Jeremy can have a look as well
okay okay let me quickly end the poll I
can see most of the folks have already
shared their responses and share the
results so I can see uh more than half
of the folks are super interested and
also uh like less than uh 40 of the
folks are pretty much interested so four
percent feeding me so I think that's
great uh so to see the interest and
curiosity in you so now uh we would we
have covered the project demo and we
have talked about machine learning uh
how you can build a recommended system
using machine learning and a lot about
other things as well so uh we would love
to know uh like what exactly is stopping
you from becoming an AIML practitioner
what is your biggest concern here so you
can see a quick pulling screen before we
start the program trivia part
so you can see uh click pull on the
screen this is a multiple choice
question so if you have multiple
concerns uh you can select from those
options here
and uh this way we'll get to know what
is your biggest concern when it comes to
becoming an email practitioner I can see
folks have started voting in and I can
see one option getting the highest
number of votes
okay I'll give five seconds more for a
few of the folks who have not shared
their biggest concern when it comes to
becoming an AIML practitioner and uh
okay okay I think we have gotten most of
the modes here so I'll give five seconds
more so five four three two one let me
quickly end the poll and share the
results
so as I can see that more than half of
the folks have shared that uh I wouldn't
get the practice exposure I need to
become job ready being their biggest
concern and I can see uh with the force
if I can't find a fully
comprehensive color and uh and if I've
shared my work schedule would allow me
in a friend for Learning and some of the
folks have also shared that I find
difficult to learn from pre-double every
video so thank you so much for sharing
your biggest concern now moving on to
the program so caltex a artificial
integers and machine learning boot camp
uh gives you a comprehensive and
Industry line curriculum and we cover
many such projects like this uh in this
program as well which we'll be talking
about in upcoming slides you'll get
access to Hands-On labs and projects and
all online virtual classrooms and this
particular program is very flexible in
terms of uh basically if you are working
somewhere if you basically are managing
uh part-time or full-time job so you can
basically easily complete this program
by just giving 10 to 15 hours per week
and this program duration is of 6 six
months
and at the end of it all you will be
getting a caltex he gave me bootcamp
certificate of AI and machine learning
bootcamp and also core elective core
certificates as well we'll be getting up
to 20 to 22 CEOs 30 that is equal to 220
hours of learning
okay okay okay I'm sorry I was taking
the chat uh so and a caltex CTA
membership as well uh in which you get
to be a part of a diverse alumni from
different different uh parts of
Industries and different different parts
profiles they come from and also uh an
online conversation where not just your
close family but your friends and
relatives can also join your convocation
so that's pretty interesting now the
eligibility I think someone asked about
the eligibility as well so you need to
have a prior experience in our knowledge
in mathematics and programming and a
high school diploma and or equivalent at
age of 18 years of age and two or more
more years of experience is required uh
not mandatory
now moving on to how this program
basically prepares you so uh Jeremy can
you take us through the uh steps uh
basically how this program builds your
aims skills
uh yeah absolutely so um
yeah so again start with an orientation
session and get sort of an introduction
to artificial intelligence in the
beginning uh this as I understand that
is actually quite surface level uh I
actually haven't taught those earlier
classes so I'm uh as I understand it
they're a pretty gentle introduction
um then we get into the applied data
science with python uh where we talk
kind of more about not so much the
machine learning yet in depth in that
class uh but we do talk a lot about kind
of the life cycle
of implementing these projects in
industry
uh what are the sort of the
practical considerations that have to be
made
um
things like cleaning the data processing
the data stuff that we saw uh kind of in
the demo today uh so we cover examples
of that
uh things like imputing missing values
dealing with outliers uh all of that
kind of stuff so and a lot of kind of
analyzing the data to get insights uh
kind of prepare yourself for the
exercise of making a model because
that's often the end goal of what we do
um then
we get into the machine learning and so
in the machine learning class we
actually get into I would say more
classical machine learning algorithms so
things like naive Bayes classifiers
um
K nearest neighbors we get into like
tree based algorithms like decision
trees and random forests
um we do talk about things like linear
regression and logistic regression which
are tragically underrated uh in fact
they're actually sort of the basis of
deep learning so you have to make sure
you understand those two algorithms very
very well if you want to understand deep
learning they also are the basis of Time
series modeling and time series analysis
which we also get into
um so yeah we cover uh kind of good
smattering a good sort of broad uh bit
of Topics in machine learning in that
class
then we move on to deep learning with
Keras and tensorflow
and that's where we actually
take what we started in the machine
learning class the things that like
linear regression and logistic
regression we ultimately extend those
ideas into feed forward artificial
neural networks which is the beginning
really of deep learning
um then we learn about uh how do we
expand this feed forward architecture to
do different things like convolutional
neural networks
for things like computer vision
um things like recurrent neural networks
for sequences
and we actually do get into Auto
encoders so we mentioned autoencoders as
a thing that happens for uh recommender
systems we do talk about Auto encoders
in that class as well
um
and there we also cover uh specific
Frameworks for how you implement this
stuff so things like tensorflow uh Pi
torch
although pytorch is really only touched
on just a bit but yeah tensorflow and
and Keras actually which is a very nice
sort of front end for tensorflow that
makes it uh much nicer to get into
um then we get into yeah the advanced
deep learning and computer vision so
that is going to focus very very much
more on things like the convolutional
neural network architecture and how that
applies to computer vision
um what that specifically does for you
like what are the advantages I know
we're pressed for time so I'm tempted to
tell you about it but I won't
um and then finally
uh you have this uh Capstone project uh
where you kind of take everything that
you've learned uh put it all together in
one big project that's actually
something you can put on your resume and
demonstrate to hiring managers uh that
you have the sort of hands-on experience
and knowledge to execute this stuff in
the real world
um and then you get your certificate
uh thank you so much Jeremy for taking
us to the steps uh also important
so you don't have to pay anything extra
for those uh so moving on what skills do
you need in order to become an AML
practitioner so as we can see there are
foundational skills learning methods and
for advanced topics Jeremy can you
quickly take us to uh these skills
uh yeah absolutely so
uh yeah so statistics and math
um so aside from statistics and
probability what you'll need in the
mathematics area is
um linear algebra absolutely uh and I
would say Vector calculus uh as well so
that we can calculate uh gradients in
higher dimensional spaces that's
ultimately something that we need to do
to optimize these models or to fit them
to data
um
yeah and then the programming piece
right to actually implement this stuff
so Python and its various libraries such
as the numpy stack
um
yeah then we do cover a variety of
learning methods so supervised and
unsupervised uh learning reinforcement
learning
um recommender systems like we just
covered and then Ensemble learning which
is actually really powerful one of my
favorite things where you're actually
combining multiple models to make one
prediction
um kind of making use of
uh this uh this knowledge of uh sorry
the this wisdom of crowds principle
right the crowds actually are often kind
of more wise than individuals in making
making guesses or predictions about
stuff
um
and then yeah and finally at the end we
get to the advanced topics which is the
Deep learning Frameworks such as Keras
and tensorflow and then
um
the things that that's actually used for
right so building neural networks
um generative adversarial networks or
Gans and actually some other topics in
generative AI
just period uh which is a Hot Topic
these days and then computer vision and
NLP which again
very much feeds into sort of the
generative AI craze right so like large
language models like GPT that kind of
stuff uh so yeah all that gets covered
to some degree
thank you so much Jeremy for taking us
through that uh also the tools and
platforms you'll be learning in this
program uh some of them being python the
jungle querass and uh Matlab and
tensorflow opencv and many more like
this uh we covered the project here uh
from one of the industrial and projects
which you'll be getting to uh basically
uh complete for your portfolio through
this program uh someone with them you
can see on this screen uh for
entertainment e-commerce tourism real
estate Healthcare and many more like
this and uh very similar to the project
project demonstration we covered in this
webinar as well uh also a capsule
project which you can showcase to your
future employees uh through this caption
project you basically can capture two
experiences which uh you can Showcase in
your portfolio a real life business
scenario and we have global leaders as
program advisors who basically make sure
that simply learn is delivering up to uh
caltex standard uh also you get to
Simply your careers Services help where
you get free access to expert webinars
real world projects across Industries
and job assist Services which I'll be
talking about next the job as a services
in this we have partnered with Talent
Inc in this you get access to job portal
resume rabbit and a resume review and
rewrite Services by top resume and also
one of my interview services from prom
interview so and the enrollment and the
program schedule of this program is the
the fee for this is 99 999 dollars and
also we have financing option of labels
for 80 dollars per month uh in case you
have any questions at
askthesis.net I'll be sharing that on
chat here so we would love to know that
would you like to enroll into the AIML
uh boot camp you can see a quick quality
screen yeah please share your interest
towards enrollment of the into the
program uh before we move on to the Q a
part of the webinar so we have gotten
great questions there and uh so sorry if
you've been not able to answer it
initially
so you can see your people on your
screen here uh so are you interested in
enrolling into the caltex AI email
bootcamp
so you can just uh quickly submit your
interest by clicking on the yes or no
option on the poll and uh
thank you
okay
uh by the way is that mean that
whiteboard area is pretty interesting
you know it gave like an old school kind
of classroom feel so we don't usually
get the that on webinars so that was a
really good idea I think let's say yeah
oh thank you yeah that's how I uh that's
how I do it in my classes that I teach
which actually Alex is one of my
students he's in the chat he said he'll
he can he can confirm for you that's uh
that's the thing I like to do nice
okay I'll I'll just keep up the poll for
10 seconds more I can see most of the
folks have shared their interest towards
enrollment and we'll be moving on to the
Q a part after this I'll I'll share the
schedule upcoming schedule I think
someone on the Q a I have asked about if
there is a deadline to register and join
the course I'll share that in the
upcoming slides so I'll give five
seconds more for the poll so folks who
have not shared their interest to what's
enrollment if you're interested in
rolling into the AML boot camp by
Caltech please do let us know on the
quick call as you see on the screen so I
think I'll just close the poll in five
seconds of five
still moving okay guys be quick we have
extended the webinar uh so remember so
we will be getting to see that if you
have a special request you can let us
know on chat or in the post webinar
survey please do that okay I think uh
most of the folks have voted uh for the
course I'll be closing the poll now
thank you so much folks for voting and
uh let's move on now to the enrollment
step so we have very uh quick three easy
simple steps you need to follow in order
to enroll you need to you need to submit
an application you can start at ask us
simply.net I'll share that email ID uh
after this and once you have submitted
your application your application will
go for review and based on the review
you'll be getting the admissions offer
later from uh simply run and also a
learning consultant we'll be reaching
out to you uh post that and the upcoming
covert for this program is on our 9th of
October and the classes will also be
starting from 9th October so if uh
someone has asked for registering and
joining the course this is the upcoming
cohort we have for this program
and now we would love to know that how
soon are you planning to join the caltex
boot camp so you can see four week
options of the screen uh folks who have
shared their interest to this enrollment
I will highly recommend to let us know
when exactly are you going to enroll
this will give us a better idea right
when to reach out to you as well and
also we would not want you to basically
lose out on the bonus of it will be
getting foreign and also patiently stay
until the end as well so that's a big
bonus to have
you know so please don't lose out on the
bonus in case uh you are still thinking
about it I would suggest to take at
least within six months or more than six
months from now if you're not starting
immediately so at least you will have
that bonus offer right which you can
apply when you start
I can see folks have started sharing
when they when do they want to enroll
that's great uh we'll be moving on to
the community part after this so if you
have not shared your query or question
uh on the Q a box please do that
immediately because you'll be moving
that to that pretty soon
okay I'll just give five seconds more
for the poll so let us know how soon do
you plan to enroll immediately within
three months within six months more than
six months from now which is the most
suitable option for you
okay I think we have got most of the
vote from the folks here thank you for
sharing that I'll be ending the poll now
and now
let's move on to the Q a part of the
webinar so uh let me just quickly browse
through it I think uh we have gotten a
very I think we've gotten a question
during the project demo
what platform do you use to build this
Jeremy
um that's a very good question so
um it depends on what you mean by
platform
um
so anything that I've done in machine
learning
for as long as I can remember has been
in Python you can do it in other
languages uh python actually though just
makes it really easy
um so yeah sometimes I'll actually do a
lot of like data analysis and
visualization in R I still like R quite
a bit for that
um but uh yeah ultimately I build stuff
in Python and depending on what it is I
might just use numpy
um you know especially if it's literally
just like a bunch of Matrix calculations
I'll just do it in numpy but I have used
scikit-learn statsmodels.api
and for a lot of
uh deep learning stuff
I use tensorflow
uh for everything I I know I actually
have some friends that are really really
big on Pi torch
um I think it's interesting I actually
have kind of wanted to check out pytorch
more
um but honestly
still I would say if you want to
actually put something in production uh
it's got to be tensorflow tensorflow is
like by far the most performant deep
learning uh framework that there is out
there and then in terms of how you
actually deploy this stuff
um
that also depends on how the model is
going to be used so sometimes your model
is like going to give like answers on
everything and the data and that's
needed like periodically
um in that case you would just set that
up on uh sort of a scheduled task or a
cron uh sort of the parlance in like
Linux based systems which is usually
what you use
um so you just have this scheduled job
that runs your model every day every
week whatever and then it'll usually
just outright it's write out its answer
to a table
for more kind of real time uh model
implementations where you need the
answer kind of again a little more ad
hoc or one-off uh I use flask a lot to
build the API that the model sits in
uh that gets containerized with Docker
and then ultimately where the docker
image goes kind of depends on you know
what they what they've decided on for
the architecture so
thank you so much let me pronouncing
that I hope your answer answer your
question please do latest on chat uh we
have gotten another interesting question
um I can't get the name but I am an RN
by profession and would like to know
what applications in healthcare and or
EHR em Master specifically epic system
does aim will have as growth areas in
coming years
uh let's see I should pop the Q a so I
can see uh so I am an RN by profession I
would like to know what
uh so there are actually Lots I've done
quite a bit of Consulting in healthcare
uh my wife is an RN as well
um
I don't really know
exactly what you specifically would do
as a registered nurse with AI but I
imagine that there are going to be a lot
of things that augment uh patient care
uh for RNs and for Physicians and other
practitioners in the near future
uh things like augmented reality
assisted by a machine learning model but
again we're ultimately probably still
going to leave that up to real people
for a while at least uh so yeah I think
there are lots and lots and lots and
lots of things there you could even use
like survival modeling to predict length
of stay right like what's the patient's
prognosis so like once they've come into
the hospital given their say diagnosis
Related Group
um how long do we expect them to be in
the hospital or say they present to the
ER
um and then they ultimately need to be
discharged or admitted how long do we
think it'll take given you know a number
of factors how busy the ER is what their
diagnosis Related Group is at triage all
that kind of stuff I think there are a
lot of different interesting modeling
applications for that particular field
uh thank you so much for answering that
Jeremy I hope that answers your question
uh I think that is the last question
we'll be taking uh now uh maybe they're
making look through if any of the
questions which are not answered uh now
moving uh to the last poll of the
session so uh for folks who have shared
the interest of your enrollment and also
share with us went to your plan to
enroll uh so do you need an assistance
in an important you can donate to the
program so you can let us know in the
quick poll you see on your screen right
now so do you need help do you need
assistance when you're trying to enroll
into the program
so you can quickly just let us know by
the quick pull on things you see on your
screen right now
I would say take the extra help you're
getting the extra help ask questions you
have over the program and before making
that up
I'll just keep this Poll for 10 seconds
more
okay so uh you know five four three two
one thank you so much for sharing if you
need assistance program so now we're
towards the end of the session uh thank
you so much for taking this time out and
even explain the time as you know for
the projective was required uh would you
like to say anything to the audience
before we end the session
um yeah just thank you so much everybody
for sticking with me uh another my I can
sometimes be a little long-winded so we
went a little bit over time but you guys
most of you've uh stuck it out and are
hanging with us even still so we really
appreciate that and I hope to see you
all in the program
thank you so much folks for joining I
just share the program link here as well
meanwhile you can share uh how you how
was the webinar for you on the chat here
and also you can share with us edition
of the post webinar surveys that
so I'll just share the program link here
on chat in case you want to look to the
uh program in much more detail so share
that on chat thank you so much I can see
folks are responding on chat here so uh
okay it was a great session
okay I think someone has asked you a
question you can answer their question
over the email I think it's related to
something else so that's okay
thank you so much Steve
good job Russia
okay fine will and end the webinar and
will be coming up with such more
webinars so stay tuned for that and have
a good night good evening good morning
where are we joining from thank you so
much folks